il s'agit d'un amendement qui concerne
les super profits et surtout les super
dividendes
on a beaucoup parlé de super profit il y
a une mission flash qui a été menée par
la commission des finances nous on pense
que c'est difficilement applicable en
l'état contenu de la fiscalité
internationale des établissements
stables et se pose la question des super
dividendes qui sont distribués et c'est
un amendement qui est encadré qui
concerne les entreprises qui réalisent
plus de 750 millions de chiffre
d'affaires qui réalisent des super
profits mais qui décident de distribuer
des super dividendes et l'idée c'est de
prévoir une flat tax à 35% pour les
super dividendes qui seraient distribués
et qui correspondrait à 20% de la
moyenne des cinq dernières années le
distribution dividendes donc il faudrait
un Coran dans la catégorie des super
profits et de que l'on puisse avoir une
notion de de super dividendes distribués
qui est quasiment encadré par la
réglementation je rappelle d'ailleurs
que pour les petits épargnants qui
recevraient des dividendes ils ont
toujours la possibilité d'obtenir
l'impôt sur le revenu ils sont pas
obligés d'être un Flac taxe donc on
pourrait considérer que cette taxe à 35
% de majoré aurait un petit caractère
confiscatoire pour des revenus moyens je
rappelle qu'il est toujours possible
d'opter un impôt sur le revenu au titre
des revenus de distribution de
dividendes ça concerne également le
rachat d'actions des sociétés puisque là
aussi on a un problème avec le rachat
d'action dans ce type de je dirais de
société qui réalise de super profit